dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here this
paper was written by scientists at deep
mind and it is about teaching an AI to
look at a 3d scene and decompose it into
its individual elements in a meaningful
manner this is typically one of those
tasks that is easy to do for humans and
is immensely difficult for machines as
this that compositional thing still
sounds a little nebulous let me explain
what it means here you see an example
scene and the segmentation of this scene
that the AI came up with which shows
what it thinks where the boundaries of
the individual objects are however we
are not stopping there because it is
also able to rip out these objects from
the scene one by one so why is this such
a big deal well because of three things
one it is a generative model meaning
that it is able to reorganize these
scenes and create new content that
actually makes sense
- it can prove that it truly has an
understanding of 3d scenes by
demonstrating that it can deal with
occlusions for instance if we ask it to
rip out the blue cylinder from this
scene it is able to reconstruct parts of
it that weren't even visible in the
original scene
with the blue sphere here amazing isn't
it and three this one is a bombshell it
is an unsupervised learning technique
now our more seasoned fellow scholars
fell out of the chair hearing this but
just in case this means that this
algorithm is able to learn on its own
and we have to feed it a ton of training
data but this training data is not
labeled it just looks at the videos with
no additional information and from
watching all this content it finds out
on its own about the concept of these
individual objects the main motivation
to create such an algorithm was to have
an AI look at some gameplay of the
Starcraft 2 strategy game and be able to
recognize all individual units and the
background without any additional
supervision I really hope this also
means that deep mind is working on a
version of their Starcraft 2 AI that is
able to learn more similarly to how a
human does which is looking at the
pixels of the game if you look at the
details this will seem almost
unfathomably difficult but would of
course make me unreasonably happy what a
time to be alive if you check out the
paper in the video description you will
find how all this is possible through a
creative combination of an attention
network and a variational auto encoder
this episode has been supported by
Backblaze Backblaze is an unlimited
online backup solution for only $6 a
month and I have been using it for years
to make sure my personal data family
pictures and the materials required to
create this series are safe you can try
it free of charge for 15 days and if you
don't like it you can immediately cancel
it without losing anything make sure to
sign up for back plays today through the
link in the video description and this
way you not only keep your personal data
safe but you also help supporting this
series thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time